anexión naval y es culpable otra vez
esta vez de fraude a gran escala la
fiscalía pide 13 años así que parece que
al líder opositor le esperan más años de
cárcel de los dos y medio que está
cumpliendo ahora mismo desde el año
pasado está en una prisión al este de
moscú por violar la libertad condicional
mientras estaba en coma hoy hemos visto
a un demacrado alexéi navalni junto a
sus abogados en una sala llena de
guardas de la prisión mientras la juez
leía las acusaciones en su contra lo
quieren enviar ahora a una colonia penal
de máxima seguridad las autoridades
rusas han presentado a naval y a sus
aliados como radicales que están
buscando desestabilizar el orden público
en rusia y a día de hoy toda la
disidencia ha sido prohibida en rusia
sobre todo en un momento en el que
muchos disidentes se marchan del país
para evitar afrontar detenciones
domiciliarias o incluso también en
ingreso en prisión